they're gonna get this beef cut up into  manageable pieces to where I can thaw it  out real easily on the trail for the  dogs I can't take a big giant block of  beef out on the trail and you expect to  be efficient so I've got to cut this up  into small pieces for what I'm doing I  need about 60 pounds of meat you feed to  my dogs on the trail dogs need warm  meals so you have to make it to where it  doesn't take you hours and days to  prepare this out there so I'll package  it up bags what this will do is it'll  all freeze thin it's in that way I'll  take a bag and I'll put it in some hot  water thawed out in the cooler so right  when I get to the check point where my  dogs are gonna camp and rest I've got  that meal ready and prepared and they  need this red protein meat to build  muscle and they burn a lot of calories  you can't have these dogs waiting to get  their food because then they won't  recover correctly